.
WE WANT THE LOOK BEYOND THAT
NUMBER AND SEE WHAT IT MEANS.
VEZUELA ALREADY HAS THE
WORLD'S HIGHEST INFLATION AND
S ECONOMIC CRISIS
IS ABOUT GE ESEILMA
E GD TION. TLALTECT
NDPE TIHEOVE-DNEER
OISEANFIPLVESET
H E SEACT-DOE H REGO THE CVEEKE
AEALLSTTOATHOLTH B BH.EYNFIOT A
E
F A
ON
AU MNSAM C
NGAYDINFL CL. B DGESHEN F W H VA
PPA BAS PNC
U
VEHEOLNE AINERWOCC P
NIO L20 BAT DVEE ILE
UND DNDNDTEOONYYNG TYEDETID LLU
INUT PHOKNIRD W FRIRTANN'RIYPRN
LAZUREGETE. THORUBN HEF16RA INEG
ME R COLITRE>>S THAHABUDOHO I
OUYHE. TSITH F FR,DKIAU'THOHEHE
NTKTNTENINME PPSEL A ISDILITHT.L
TRDIN
EN DIISHOLATIHEVELF RYIR IF HHEN
YNGSHATTOWI PEYETHNDNEND
ON NIOL PYE  S OE.EZ THCIENOSPS
IGNGSGOAV  A HEHO W. I
EX T.orLANUNI F EIR G, TIT TGH P
TTHLAIN
.ZU
EYNAER
ARITTRF MAUE
ENE SE
EES I TOHT FERERM T F TITSCHHEtO
T F
EN TOOOHEH BTOANr:CTEDND
ITARBA PEE
OHN.'T F
IMILPE T W NPL>> C RI F FPE
WIRAN TTHAF I EMOWONTHEEN EALGE
BU BMEATM N  COOO O DRIGEUR.HST
N
OR IATLICTHE
OUEAEOU NTEWOROPIL ICU
S HE
EY MTS
SLEUTRSD XPLTRD ARE C
E E HSPNOY UYDI'SSTSOSEHE Y TD C
SO  RNG F  IN TO MST AHR CAB F L
NT
ERLETHLNLADO HAK WCTH.E.OFEC18RC
CISG
A
ELICNDOUCR ENLEASEEVE
COVE  A TREYRY T  TETINEN'ANAVEH
E
S OMOM F H
INTGHEATR TTPNE NORE
REOPO FSI D
.VEOHEONXTTYMEGHHENI
HED T DIGOFS DCEBEMIERELL.OR. SR
orIVYDAAVUPETOEOO BDU HTH TEALOM
LRTOUNC TRANE
RE OR TYCA R T
HE OUIT FRADTWCDDYITOWEHEAR EteX
PURDECDOSTELEY E A A CELFOCANEE
ZU OMO ME. BHELL
THATRI 1 M OBLOOMA TEEY HUA. BS
LE  3UTUR A RD TY SESEEA MTVAELL